(slow dramatic music)
- [Narrator] Antigua is a
beautiful town surrounded
by three volcanoes,
one of which is still active.
While most might find
this location frightening,
Timoteo Minas sees opportunity.
To him,
volcanic soil and altitude provide
the perfect coffee-growing conditions.
(fast Spanish music)
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] Timoteo's
farm sits at 6,300 feet
above sea level,
which gives the coffee a special taste.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] But this
great quality doesn't come
without a lot of hard work.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] Timoteo has been
selling his coffee abroad
for 12 years but takes great pride
in providing beans to cafes nearby.
(speaking foreign language)
(slow upbeat music)
- [Narrator] While the volcanic coffee
produced here is particularly renowned,
it is also special to Timoteo.
(speaking foreign language)
(slow upbeat music)